Eva this is an amazing physics effect or
it's a magical flying boat so as
Guillermo a trickster or as science
behind this bafflingly buoyant boat
while at the beach geese mo has managed
to capture on his camera and optical
illusion known as fata morgana
the fata morgana is seen when there is
what's known as an inversion layer in
the atmosphere typically the temperature
of the air gets cooler as you go from
the ground upwards but when there's an
inversion layer the air near the ground
is coolest and there's warm air above it
during the day the Sun heats the
atmosphere but over the ocean the part
of the atmosphere that's closest to the
surface is actually cooler because of
its contact to water and cooler air is
actually more dense and so what this
means is we get layers of atmosphere at
different density the fata morgana
illusion is very uncommon because
usually the wind mixes all these layers
around in this day the wind was quite
still so the layers were well defined
when light hits the boat it gets
reflected and travels through these
layers all the way back to Guillermo
eyes light travels faster in less dense
areas and a lot slower in colder more
dense areas so the path that the light
follows gets bent Guillermo is watching
the ship from the land and because the
light pass has been bent and he's
accustomed to light traveling in
straight lines it appears that the ship
is in the air and not sitting on the
surface of the ocean in other words it's
the final Morgana that floats this boat
you
[Music]
you